Impossible?
What is impossible?
Was it impossible for the humble son of an Alabama cotton farmer...
...to enter the politically charged arena of Berlin,...
...win four gold medals, the hearts of the world...
...and become the true message and lasting memory of the 1936 Olympics?
Was it impossible for a young girl...
...who, at the age of six, was diagnosed with incurable polio,...
...whose doctors told her she would require leg braces for the rest of her life,...
...to go on to win three gold medals in Rome?
Was it impossible for an athlete who one day decided...
...to jump over the bar backwards instead of forwards,...
...who was laughed at and booed at every track meet,...
...to go on to win gold and revolutionize his sport in the process?
Was it impossible for a man who barely qualified for the Olympic finals...
...to take off into the thin air of Mexico City...
...and land somewhere in the next century, shattering a world record...
...that had hardly changed over four decades by 55 centimeters?
Was it impossible that the first gymnast to score a perfect ten...
...would also be the second to score a perfect ten, the third, the fourth,...
...the fifth, the sixth and the seventh at the age of 13?